You think you know the story of Dracula.
You have no idea.
Before the legend there was the man, Vlad the Impaler.
He was a warrior, he was a leader,...
...but also he was a family man trying to do right by his people.
He's in that really diabolical situation, giving his son away...
...or fighting a war which is almost impossible to win.
You can't protect us.
It becomes about keeping their family together at all costs.
What Vlad is about to enter into is the ultimate sacrifice.
Because men do not fear swords,...
...they fear monsters.
It's a story of torment and sacrifice and love and violence and power.
They will not be defeated!
This is not who you are.
It's so much fun to be taken on this ride.
There's always a price for power.
People will know the real person behind Dracula and not just the man with the fangs.